turn into your weather now typically we
see just lots of sunshine in the eight
day forecast we have not seen that
lately we've seen a lot of cloud cover
and a lot of showers and that continues
as well all right taking a look right
now at the rain tallies we had today
because some of you had some heavier
showers earlier today that was mainly
focused on the northwest and West part
of the valley to the Southwest not so
much we picked up a trace out at read
today for hundredths of an inch on the
strip 400s down there towards Green
Valley so good to see some measurable
rain not a lot but we'll take what we
can get 49 Centennial Hills for you
right now new neighborhoods here to show
you Spring Valley 52 54 from North Las
Vegas the east side coming in at 60s for
Sunrise Manor 58 for you at Whitney
Ranch 57 Henderson and 51 for Mountains
Edge and Rose Ranch Southern Highlands
you're currently at 53 degrees elsewhere
outside of town we're at 56 over the
hump right now on Pahrump double fives
for you in Sandy Valley Boulder City
right now you're at 57 degrees so more
storms lined up it's kind of like a
bowling ball alley right one bowling
ball after the other just lined up
headed to the Pacific coast and that's
what we've been seeing lately now the
latest one that's impacting us the one
behind that is going to head up to the
Pacific Northwest and that'll give us a
brief break all right even California
get a little slight break after this
rainfall that we're seeing right now in
California notice this will go
underneath the Sierras and up towards us
we're already seeing some spillover
right now with some shower activity that
we saw earlier today and this will
continue for this evening so here's your
future cast nine o'clock tonight could
see some of the heavier showers start to
pick up again 10 o'clock at night same
story some rain around the Region 8 News
9 11 is starting to clear out just a
little bit I'll be off the top here
possibly on the weather deck I'll wait
and see to let you know about this
rainfall for late night tonight mainly
east County and then we could see
another impulse move through again by
the time we come in about 4 a.m and 1
a.m in the morning this is about time
good day goes on a little break in the
morning 2 p.m notice more rainfall
moving in from the West this could have
some embedded thunderstorms along with
it to some heavier showers along with
this one along with the wind too notice
by the time we get to 7 PM starting to
clear out a bit remember we're on as
early as 3 P.M so I will be the top of
every little shows to walk you through
that make sure everything's okay and
show you what to expect throughout the
day on all our weather casts your wind
speeds are going to pick up again
tomorrow remember there's a wind
advisory begins right here at noon it
will Peak around 40 to 45 miles per hour
before those winds die off later on in
the evening for tomorrow so here's your
forecast your eight to eight planner
temperatures are going to be around 60
degrees mild but there's your rainfall
starting to pick up midday the afternoon
slight chances early evening and then
light chances are mainly clear chances
by the time we get to the even clearing
out actually as far as your temperatures
go we'll be hovering on high 50s to low
60s there's your brief what we call
respite okay a little break Wednesday
through Friday before those chances
increase again for the weekend and
through MLK holiday and only slight
chances on Tuesday as the rain in
continues that's your most accurate
forecast here on 8 news now Denise over
to you